but a lot of fans don't want a remake of
babyon 5 they're actually quite angry
about it I get lots of comments go and
have a look at any of my babyon 5 videos
about people saying for the love of God
don't do this don't do a
remake Farscape though that's not what
they're thinking according to one of my
sources that's actually spoken to people
at Brian Henson's production company
personally Brian Henson is once again
pushing a continuation of Farscape now
this is not the first time he's tried to
do this going back five or six years he
was really pushing very hard but
actually only a couple of years ago in
2019 he was seriously trying to get this
done and he was even talking about the
original cast returning then